she's one of a new wave of female
independents targeting seats held by
australia's ruling coalition party
frustrated by the two-party stalemate on
climate change the
journalist-turned-politician says people
voting in the election this weekend want
policies backed by science and immediate
action i think the reason that many of
the independents have focused on climate
is because that's what the australian
people want they want faster better more
focused economic action on climate
policy and they haven't got it
australia is one of the highest emitters
of greenhouse gases in the world per
capita and is the second largest
exporter of coal
it's also one of the nation's most at
risk from climate change
a scientific study warns australia will
become uninsurable by the end of this
decade unless emissions are drastically
reduced flooding was the most common
risk followed by bushfires
climate change is already hitting many
australian communities very hard one
area we find this is it's becoming
harder for people to insure their homes
some recent research we did show that by
2030 one in 25 australian properties
could be effectively uninsurable higher
than average temperatures have again
caused severe bleaching in parts of the
great barrier reef
next month unesco will assess whether
the australian government has done
enough to address threats to the coral
with the world heritage committee
considering listing it as in danger
now the great barrier reef has just
experienced its sixth mass bleaching
event due to marine heat have been
exacerbated by climate change and it's
disappointing because the current
administration is not taking this
seriously
the government and the opposition have
committed to a zero net emission target
by 2050 both major parties continue to
support fossil fuels with more than 100
new coal and gas projects on the
government's official register climate
scientists say their policies fall short
of what's needed to limit warming to
below two degrees
the largest voter survey in australia
found that at least one third of people
consider climate change as the most
important issue in this election and
what action to reduce emissions by 2030
but some coal towns lie in swing
constituencies and it's those
electorates that are key to winning this
election sarah clark al jazeera sydney
australia